but you could bang you could bring your
fiance and bang her is that a good story
do you have a good story about banging
your fiance anal first time did you do
that
we have
but so the second time can't be oh you
only did it once yeah but that's a story
I'm throwing out there you wouldn't do
anal right that's pretty messy I I don't
think I don't think I want to but tell
me about your anal story tell me about
did you was it your idea uh it was her
idea uh yeah but it's uh it's quite a
balloon knot back there it's hard to I
don't know how these Gales in the movies
do it with the real pounding because uh
it's a lot of
like so you said to her she's like was
it a plan she brought it up what did she
say she said hey uh we should try this
all my friends are doing it uh I want
you to like me and I'm like I like you
we don't was she already the fiance yeah
so she had the ring yes so it wasn't for
the ring she wasn't trying to tease you
it sounds like peer pressure if she said
all her friends are doing it yeah but
and and not only are all her friends
doing it but they're talking about it oh
yeah girls do that they do that girls
talk so girls will get together like and
and this go I've had a I'm so it so go
ahead so she says all my friends did it
yeah and maybe I'm not satisfying her in
the the original hole so maybe she wants
to try a new one maybe that could be it
I have low self-esteem so that's where
my brain goes yeah how long ago is this
a couple months
and so this is fresh fresh anal and uh
have you talked about this on your show
oh yeah yeah story Tuesday stories oh
yeah so you talked about this so it's
not a new it's not a new story
no you're not getting an anal exclusive
I'm sorry but I'm on open casket
whatever you want I'll talk about is
that what you call it yeah yeah there's
a lot of dead bodies in that ass but I
didn't hear this story so I'll I'll I'll
I'll just uh well it's not much of a
story I'm just so so she says to you all
my friends are doing it yep
and we said okay let's make a night out
of it we made a whole night yeah we got
some candles we got a tarp you know we
got some lube and tarp well you could
could get messy
so you really went you go to you went to
um where do you go like Home Depot and
you asked for an anal tarp yeah pretty
much oh you get like a slip and slide
any kind of duveteen will do
is it duveteen or duveteen duveteen okay
what did I say Louboutin I don't know
Louboutin there's a Louboutin is a tarp
with the red bottom oh really I think
that's Louboutin those are shoes ah the
red bottom shoes the red bottom Louis
Vuitton
no oh Louboutin a Louboutin Louis
Vuitton is the v's and the L's uh that
they made a pattern and they and that's
luggage I think so right it's a pattern
well we're going down a real add anal
Rabbit Hole here but it's like okay what
is she what does she do for a living
she's has a uh she's a comedian but she
also does the like a real nine to five
what is her nine to five job
something with influencing and marketing
she influenced you to stick it in her
ass yeah she's an influencer yeah we
tried it was too tight I couldn't you
couldn't do it couldn't do it all the
veins wouldn't fit did she did she
um say stop before you said I can't get
in well I put a pinky just the tip of
them she was like ah stop and I was like
oh what what's going on she's like oh
you put it in and I was like that was a
tip of the pinky and she was like so she
didn't know the difference between your
pinky and your penis yes well she
thought that was no but I like the idea
that you you decided you you knew what
you were going for well you got to start
somewhere and you started with the
pinkies yeah like she's lying on her
stomach yes and you just you first you
laid down the tarp yeah and uh you got
the lube yep did you put Lube on your
pinky I did yeah do you uh and then with
your pinky you just lowered your pinky
into her like a dipstick like a dipstick
like like when you stick your toe in a
cold pool exactly like you didn't want
to do that so you just stuck your pinky
in and it was the same reaction of a
cold pool she went man man kind of
flipped out yeah and she was like what
was that I was like that was just the
tip of my but why would you like Jesus I
know but more but I love that she went
whoa what is that when it was her idea
through her girlfriends like she was
surprised yeah yeah so she has a
short-term memory issue well I think
when there's no rear view camera when
you're doing anal it's not like a new
Kia you know so this she doesn't know
what's going on back there she could
think I'm using a pepper shaker
okay and and
no so what do we get on Loveline I'm so
confused no I just I'm fascinated okay
okay I've been married to the same woman
for 42 years and I'm really asking these
questions because I'm sitting here with
my kid and I think it's time we had to
talk and I'm letting you be part of the
talk you're what you're learning
something Jack uh no I'm actually
sitting back I don't think I could
contribute to this conversation at all
have you tried the uh
it's not about her I don't want to bring
me into the conversation he just wants
that you're asking my daughter you wow
she's a grown lady yeah but but you
don't ask my daughter you don't ask a
woman in front of her father have you
had the butt play well you're asking me
in front of your daughter but your
parents not here
have you talked to your parents about it
they died
they're doing anal
[Music]